everything is changing everything
always has been changing but now it is
changing
so quickly that within the confines of
an individual life
the entire cosmic drama it can be
encapsulated we are each practical
histories of the universe it is
within us as a community as individuals
nothing can stop this this is not a
political movement
this is as inevitable as continental
drift
or the sunspot cycle you know it is
now time to decamp from
three-dimensional space
20 you know 15 000 years ago it was
time for the descent from the garden
into history
to take hold of the tools that will
allow us
to free our minds our bodies our planet
our identity our destiny this
is what it's all been about we'll
redefine
sanity
this is what's insane the city outside
and the governments and the institutions
we won't become insane
we are awakening this is what's
happening
the long nightmare of human history that
james joyce
talked about we are awakening
and the truth you think you see the
truth of your own intuition
is the truth you don't need somebody
handing this stuff
down from on high you simply have to
open your eyes you know if it looks like
your
shoes if it talks like horseshit
if it drops like worship
[Music]
is
[Music]
you